I've ruled on this issue already in the
past but it it seems necessary for me to
speak up again because it is shocking to
me how many people are wrong about this
how many people don't understand one of
one of the basic rules of etiquette and
of life so here's a quick viral video
making the rounds right now uh it is an
argument on an airplane over the issue
of reclining your seat let's watch the
whole she plac my seat no you seen it no
she didn't she put no I'm allowed to put
my seat back I'm allowed to put my seat
back I'm allowed to put my seat back
okay so I I don't know where this video
is from but it's making the rounds right
now I don't know if it's a recent or not
I don't know the any other context
behind it I don't know who those people
are but I think we can uh we can we can
assume from the context that it's that
that this dispute started because the
woman was putting her seat back and the
guy behind her did not like that and
apparently from what I read she he was
kicking the seat or something um
and so it is apparently necessary as I
did on Twitter this morning uh it's
apparently necessary for me to uh
stipulate once again you do not recline
your seat in coach okay if you want the
right to recline your seat get a first
class ticket you can recline your seat
in first class
okay because there's enough room and and
you can recline your seat without
impeding the person behind you
um and uh and and also there are pract
like in first class for example the tray
table most of the time is not attached
to the seat in front of you usually In
First Class they have the tray table
that comes out of the armrest which
means that if person behind you reclines
a bit it's not going and you're trying
to eat uh your your meal on your trade
table it's not going to interfere
but in coach the trade table is attached
to the seat behind you and so often
times if you if you have a trade table
down and the person reclines the trade
table is not even usable anymore can't
use
it and then there's and then uh there's
the the uh the the leg room issue okay
um you only have you have like two
inches of leg room to spare if you're in
coach you have barely any barely any leg
room to begin with you got maybe 2 Ines
is Despair and when I say top spare I
mean like there's you might if if you
are yeah look if you're if you're a very
short person this might be
different but if you are even average
height or slightly above average height
um you've got where your knee ends and
then you've got maybe like two inches
before it's hitting the seat in front of
you if that person declines that room is
gone now and now you your knee is wedged
up against that person's reclined seat
just because and I don't want to hear
well I'm as she's arguing I'm allowed to
recline my seat I'm allow yeah you're
allowed to you're allow there's no
unfortunately there's no law saying you
can't there should be a law but there's
not you're you're allowed to do a lot of
things that you should you still
shouldn't do that's what etiquette is
there is not force of law behind most
rules of etiquette again if I was in
charge that it would be but I'm not
unfortunately for everybody so but that
doesn't that doesn't invalidate the rule
of etiquette there's no hey you're
allowed to walk in to walk through a
door and shut it on the person behind
you you're allowed to do that the door
is you're you're able to do
that does that mean you should do that
does that make it not incredibly rude to
do
that you know here's another
analogy for all the people that let say
well the seats the seats can recline
like is
that is is that how simple your mind is
that you say well it can do it so that
means I should do
it yeah it can do it but you
shouldn't just like the VA take this
maybe you live in an apartment okay you
have a TV you're allowed to have a TV in
your apartment that TV goes up to a
certain volume right it goes up to
volume 75 or whatever so you're allowed
to have a TV you're allowed to be in
your apartment the TV is is you're able
to turn it all the way up it has that
capability but should you put the TV on
full blast so that you're disturbing the
people who live around you no even
though you can even though uh you're
able
to you still shouldn't because it is
rude to the people around
you and when you decide to recline your
seat in coach you are making the
decision to invade the personal space of
the person behind you and to take what
little Comfort they had away from them
okay and you're doing a you're trying to
increase your comfort by a little
bit uh by taking uh the the the Comfort
away from the person behind you that is
by definition a a rude thing to
do all right uh moving on actually we're
not going to move on because as move on
to uh the next segment it will we will
stay on this very important subject
let's get to that now our friends at
genus cell have launched a new product
called genu cell 3 which works fast on
your under eye bags and puffiness genu
cell 3 is smoother more luxurious and it
uses advanced technology to deliver
complex vitamins and minerals directly
to your face for instant hydration it's
like Gatorade for your skin this new
genu cell technology keeps your skin
looking young and healthy for years to
come the genu cell fall Classics package
also includes a jawline treatment for a
more firm neck and jawline it also
includes J cell's anti- wrinkle
moisturizer and deep Firming Serum of
course any genus cell Luxury Box isn't
complete without the great genucel XV
anti- wrinkle moisturizer and their
world famous deep Firming Serum get your
skin ready for the cold and dry weather
if you don't look and feel your absolute
best you'll get your money back no
questions asked go to genucell.com Walsh
or you can call 800 sk21 for extra
discounts on this amazing fall package
get results in 12 hours or less the
immediate effects are included for free
that's jal.com Walsh or by calling 800
skin
to11 okay so as I mentioned we talked
about this or I I uh I I want to go say
I gave my opinion on the leg room or the
seat reclining issue I didn't give my
opinion I stated what is a fact on
Twitter this morning and
uh shockingly a large percentage of
people somehow are disagreeing with me
so I'll read a few of these comments um
she's right Matt the reclining function
is there to be used you decide or need
to fly bear with it that doesn't entitle
the person behind you to push and kick
the seat in front Abby says seats
recline a tiny amount it's hardly
noticeable to either party smooth op
says I'm putting my back it is what it
is I've paid for that seat and all the
amenities that come with
it Dr Dre I don't know if he's the the
one and only says disagree it only
reclines about an inch and the back
table is still usable Cara says these
seats are designed to be the smallest
possible to maximize Airline profits why
does logic always elude you Matt and
Aaron says the seats only recline a
couple of inches stop being a drama
queen fly first class if you really care
about leg room that much okay number one
I do fly first class this is me I'm
speaking up uh for the common man here
okay I'm speaking so I'm not even
personally affected by this anymore but
but even so I still it it enrages me to
know that the people back there are
suffering in this way I almost want to
give my seat up for them I well no I
would never do that but still I don't
like to know that this kind of that this
rudess is happening and also because of
the rudeness that this great suffering
is happening as well um it only reclines
a couple of inches that's true but once
again there there is only a couple of
inches back there to spare to begin with
and so you're taking away what what
rightfully belongs to the person behind
you now who's the ultimate villain in
all this is it the airline yes I totally
agree with
that okay the airlines they they're
treating their their passengers like
cattle basically just shoving them back
there and uh and then on top of it they
have the reclin function on the seats
which is insane like why do you even
have why are the seats able to do that
it's
crazy um
so they are to blame ultimately for this
but um
look we get into the plane especially if
we're sitting back and
Coach you know as they said during Co
we're all in this together and uh and we
should have a lot more room we don't we
shouldn't be treated like cattle but we
are and so we all just need to you we
just got to work together a little bit
okay you don't very you don't very often
hear me with the kind of Kumbaya message
but this is one of those
times and and usually when you see these
incidents on planes it's it's it's a
high stress situation traveling is high
stress people are their nerves are are
already
frayed and uh and so you just got to
just like basic etiquette basic
politeness um be considerate to the
people around you in just real basic
small
ways uh and there's all you know if
there's someone on the plane that's not
cooperating with that program it just
all hell breaks
loose so that's it
this should be the last time that we
have to talk about
this the rule has been stated again
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts